out of all the things happening in the
AI space right now Cloud's model context
protocol definitely seems to have the
biggest Spotlight and for good reason
it's an incredible protocol developed by
anthropic to standardize the way that we
give tools to our llms for them to do
things with our services and everyone is
covering this right now and they're
doing a good job with their content but
usually the videos I see are either
diving into the weeds building something
cool with mCP or explaining it at a high
level without any examples what I know
you need and what I'm going to cover
right now is a comprehensive overview of
mCP everything you have to know at a
high level like what it is why it's
important and how you can start using it
today to boost your productivity and
build better AI agents and the thing
about mCP unlike other things in the AI
space is it is not going anywhere
anytime soon we've had a lot of Sparks
recently as I like to call them Manis
open AI operator deep seek R1 these
things that have generated so much hype
initially but then that spark dies down
in just a couple of weeks contrast this
with mCP it's like a kindling log
instead of a dwindling spark and it's
just going to keep getting hotter and
hotter and it's not even new it's been
around since November of last year it's
just that people are realizing more and
more over time how useful and Powerful
it really is and that is the sign that
it is much more than just hype it's why
I've been investing so much time into
learning it more recently and I'd
recommend you to do do the same simply
put if you use mCP to enhance your llms
and AI agents you have an unfair
advantage over those who don't and that
is not going away anytime soon so allow
me to catch you up on everything you
need to know and towards the end of this
video I'll even show you how to
integrate mCP with n8n and your python
agents with some templates for you to
download right now a lot of value packed
into this shorter video so let's go
ahead and dive right into it so here is
the official documentation for mCP I'll
link to this in the description and
we're going to be using this as a
reference a lot as we go through all of
the important Core Concepts in their
introduction page the home page of the
docs they have a nice quick and simple
definition of what mCP is you can think
of it like the USBC ports for AI
applications so just like we use USB to
in a standard way connect our devices
very easily to all of our peripherals we
use mCP as a standardized way to very
easily connect our tools to our llm
another way to think about it an analogy
that I've heard a lot recently is mCP is
like API endpoints for our AI agents so
just like companies create apis to
expose their backend services to other
applications mCP is the way to expose
tools for AI agents very nice and simple
and I like the mCP docs here they're
pretty comprehensive but definitely
missing a lot and some of their diagrams
I feel like could explain things a lot
better but I don't mind that because
that allows me and other Educators to
swoop in and really help things click
for you so that's what we're going to do
right now not just talking about what
mCP is but why it's so useful as well
and I've got a couple of neat diagrams
to help make that clear so the first
beautiful diagram that I made just for
you that I want to show is what AI
agents look like before we had mCP
because in the end telling you what mCP
is and why it's so useful is best done
by starting with what we had to deal
with before it was available to us and
so right here we have an AI agent this
could be built with pantic AI crew AI NN
it doesn't matter because in the end
with AI agents you create all of these
functions that are tools given to the AI
agent so you create a function to make a
file to make a commit and git to list
our tables in our database and with
documentation we tell the AI agent when
and how to use each tool so that through
conversation it can do all these things
on our behalf and it's pretty powerful
this is what makes AI agent truly an AI
agent instead of just a regular chatbot
or a workflow it can reason about based
on the things we say oh I need to go and
update this file and then make this push
to get and then update this record in
superbase for example but we start to
hit a wall if we want to reuse these
tools for another AI agent that we're
making because what if I started with
building an agent with pantic AI but
then I want to build another agent with
something like n8n or maybe I want to
use these tools within claw desktop or
wind surf or some other AI IDE it's not
really possible to reuse all of these
tools that I created just as individual
functions so I end up rewriting a lot of
that functionality and it gets even
worse if you're sharing things between
different people like how would you take
this as a neat little package and just
give it to someone for them to use with
their AI agent no matter what framework
they are using and so you get to this
point where you're developing a lot of
redundant code for yourself or
individual people are recreating these
tools to do a very similar thing over
and over and over again and that is why
we need standardization we need a neat
way to package all the tools for
Individual Services in a way that we can
share with other people and reuse
ourselves between our applications and
our different agent Frameworks and that
is exactly what mCP gives us all of
those nice little packages created in a
standardize way so that we don't have
this question here of how do we take
these tools and reuse them for more use
cases so we aren't creating the same
code over and over again so now on to
the second diagram this shows what our
agent looks like when it's upgraded to
use mCP so now instead of having to
Define all of those individual tools and
functions we have these services that
our mCP servers expose that communicate
all these tools to our AI agent and
allow them to use it in a way where it
doesn't matter if we're creating our
agent with n8n or we're using cursor or
we're building with pantic AI we can
consume these Serv servers in exactly
the same way because these mCP servers
are a middleman to standardize the way
that these tools are given to the agent
and under the hood things look exactly
the same like with our superbase service
this mCP we have the same tools here but
through the mCP protocol these superbase
tools that are available they are
communicated to the AI agent so through
this route the agent knows what
superbase tools are available and then
the way that our AI agent uses the tools
under the hood is still exactly the same
so there's nothing new and revolutionary
here with the model context protocol
it's not changing the way that tools are
used it's just making it easy to reuse
these tools and package them together
neatly and so for example if this first
agent was built with pantic AI we can
include these mCP servers in cursor for
example we have a second host and it's
still going to be using these servers in
the same way so there'll be a separate
instance of the server but it's going to
be using the exact same code under the
hood so there's no redundancy we don't
have to recreate these servers or these
tools and under the hood it all looks
the same just using the same tools that
are available in that same service and
I'm saying same a lot because that's the
important part of the standardization
now I'm throwing my full face on the
screen again because there's something
very important that I mentioned earlier
that I want to reemphasize and that is
the fact that under the hood with mCP AI
agents are still using Tools in exactly
the same way way because in the end the
tools that these servers expose are just
given as a part of the prompt to the llm
so the agent can decide that it wants to
use a tool and then it'll produce a
specific output to make that tool call
happen a big misconception that a lot of
people have been communicating is that
mCP is somehow revolutionary in the way
that it provides these capabilities for
llms that we never had before and that
my friend is simply not true because
we've always had access to these tools
TOS to do things with our llms but mCP
just makes it standard like we've been
saying to make it more accessible and
easier to create these packages of tools
to share with other people so still
insanely powerful just not a brand new
technology that unlocks this next level
of capability so with that word of
warning out of the way let's dive more
into these mCP servers and where we can
use them so back here in the mCP docs if
you go to example clients you can see
this list and I'm not sure if it's
compreh ensive but it shows you so many
different apps that support the model
context protocol so you've got your AI
idees like Klein rine wind surf cursor
you've got your apps like claw desktop
and n8n you can use this in Frameworks
like pantic AI crew aai Lang chain seems
like everything is supporting mCP these
days because it's becoming such a big
deal and the whole tool standardization
that's the main thing that supported
with all of these different clients
there are some other parts to mCP like
resources prompts sampling and Roots
which are pretty cool like resources
I'll just show you this really quick
resources you can expose data to your
llms that that's updated in real time
things like files and database records
you can share prompt templates with llms
through mCP you can do sampling which
lets you uh request completions from
llms as a tool it's so cool and like the
thing with all of these different
features you can see that they're not
really supported by most of these
clients and so they're they're very much
more experimental and still being
developed that's why the big Focus right
now is just on the tool standardization
definitely something worth watching as
these things are more developed out by
anthropic and the open source Community
but right now yeah just focusing on
tools to start so that's clients and
I'll show you how to build a custom one
with python later but let's go on to the
fun part the servers that are already
available for us to do things with our
file system and Google Drive for example
and they show also how to get this all
set up in claw desktop we'll do that in
a sec but first I want to show you this
official mCP GitHub repo that has a list
of a bunch of servers that you can use
right now so they have the official ones
developed by anthropic the official
integration so these companies built mCP
servers themselves for you to use their
services and then you have
community-driven ones as well and it is
amazing the number of services that are
available to us already as mCP servers
is astounding to me and you can always
build one yourself if there's something
that isn't available here yet and you've
got things like Brave search for example
so a lot of llms already have web search
like chat gbt for example but Claude and
your local llms they don't and so you
can use this as a server for that you
can have a server to manage your redis
database or your postgress database with
superbase even and then with these
official Integrations there's so many
incredible companies already working
hard to integrated with mCP like browser
base for example they have a headless
browser as a service for things like web
crawling and scraping they have this sub
platform called stageand there's an mCP
server for it you can literally with
natural language have your AI agent
crawl websites pull specific information
it's just incredible and then you've got
quadrant for example for rag you don't
even have to implement custom rag tools
you can just use this quadrant mCP and
then for each of these mCP servers
they're either going to be built with
JavaScript or Python and so depending on
how they're built you're going to be
running them with a different service so
the Brave search mCP server for example
you can run with either Docker or MPX
and so you can just go ahead and install
something like Docker desktop or you can
install node.js to have access to that
MPX command and then other mCP servers
are built with python like the chroma
Vector database mCP server and so you
run this uh with uvx which if you have
python installed you can just pip
install uvx to run that command and all
of these instructions they also tell us
how to set it up in cloud desktop and
you can take these instructions and use
that to set it up in anything else like
n8n or wind surf or cursor and so it's
always going to be very standard just
tweaking in a little bit and so with
claw desktop for example the way that
you can set up these servers if you go
to the top left click on file and then
settings you can go to the developer tab
and then edit your configuration right
here so it's going to open up this
folder on your computer and then I can
open up my config in something like vs
code and then here is my Json my
configuration for all of my mCP servers
that I set up just following the guides
in the GitHub repo and so I've got
access to my file system brave for web
search sequential thinking which is
super cool I've got memory which is kind
of like a basic implementation of
something like mzero or Zep then I've
got stage hand this is the one that I
showed earlier which is really cool
you're able to with natural language
have the agent crawl websites for you
and then I've got archon which is my mCP
server for the AI agent Builder that
I've been working on on my channel so
all of my mCP servers so with that back
over to CLA desktop I can see all of the
tools available by clicking on this
Hammer icon it's going to look very
similar for wind Surf and cursor as well
so this gives me all my tools and a
description of each of these and so now
I can ask it a question that is going to
require it to use these tools in
conjunction together to do things for me
so in this case first it's going to have
to use the brave search to query for the
pantic AI docs and then once it finishes
that query and gets the link to pantic
AI it's going to have to use stageand
there we go because it needs to visit
that page and so we're using the
stageand navigate tool so it's going to
process that for me and then come back
and use the next tool so there we go yep
it found the models page and now it
wants to take a screenshot super cool
and browser base is really neat with
Stage handier I can actually go into
their UI go to sessions take a look at
this running session and sure enough it
is here on the pantic AI models page and
I can go back to Claude and I can ask it
questions about this as well it's just
super neat and these are just examples
of some of the tools that I could be
using I've got a lot of them set up but
just look at how easy it is to use these
tools together to do some awesome things
all right we have covered a lot already
so let's just go ahead and take a
breather so at this point we definitely
understand mCP at a pretty high level
what it is why it's so important how we
can leverage it and we use clae desktop
as an example but you could look up the
documentation for something like cursor
for example they're sure to have it the
setup is going to be very similar to
Claude desktop but now I want to dive
into building with mCP we can create our
own servers to package our own tools and
we can also create our own clients so we
can build AI agents with Frameworks like
pantic AI that can leverage mCP servers
for the agent tools and this entire
video has definitely been a crash course
I'm just giving you what you need at a
high level and so I'm going to go pretty
quick through these building pieces with
mCP but but just let me know in the
comments what you want me to do a
dedicated video to to dive into in more
detail cuz I'm definitely going to be
creating more mCP content very soon and
I would love to do a deep dive into
building an mCP server or integrating
mCP with n8n or pantic AI so just let me
know but right now I'm going to go over
things pretty quickly give you some
templates to get started so you can dive
into this yourself so first up building
your own mCP server very important and
I'm almost certainly going to be making
a dedicated video on this in the future
there are a few different pages in the
docs that I want to call out really
quick so first if you go to for Server
developers they give you a good example
how to build a simple weather mCP server
with a couple of tools for dealing with
weather data and then depending on the
SDK you want to use like if you want to
build a python mCP server I'd highly
recommend checking this out it'll bring
you right to GitHub where you can go
through examples for the specific
language you're interested in and
there's a lot more information here so
not going to dive into this now because
the really important thing that I want
to show is building mcps with llms cuz
let's face it as much as Vibe coding is
something I don't really trust we're all
using AI coding assistance to at least
get us started with our projects and so
Claude in the mCP docs shows you how to
do that so you can visit this llm d.
text and this is going to give you the
entire mCP documentation and markdown so
you can copy and paste into your
favorite AI IDE so I can copy this go
into something like wind surf for for
example and then just paste that whole
sucker in there and I can ask it to use
that to then build me an mCP server and
so for example I could have it build a
brave server if I wanted to and also
within win Sur if you can just reference
the mCP documentation directly you can
do this in other AI IDs I believe as
well at cursor so very powerful you have
both options but I can say yeah use
these docs to build an mCP server that
searches the web with brave boom and I
can just send this in I'll let it do its
thing it's going to search through all
the documentation create a bunch of code
for me and I'll come back once it's
built and look at this it built us a
full mCP server and I'm not looking
through all the code in insane detail
I'm not going to run it right now either
just because I wanted to show this
really briefly but this looks really
solid it looks like a very well-coded
mCP server I'll accept all these changes
it's got the tool for the brave web
search even uses a couple of different
API endpoints for brave which is super
neat and it gives me example claw
desktop configuration a readme it did
everything for me I mean part of this is
just wind surf being great but yeah like
it used all the documentation for mCP to
build this for me and I know that brave
is just kind of a a demo example you
would probably want to build something
that isn't already available on the
GitHub repo but yeah I think I'll do a
dedicated video on this later where I'll
build an mCP server from scratch doing
something that isn't available already
because in the end there are a lot of
different services that don't have mCP
servers and you want to make really
custom servers sometimes that maybe are
combining different tools together or
working with local llms that you have
set up I mean there's Endless
Possibilities next up we've got n8n you
can integrate mCP servers directly in
your n8n AI agents and it's all using
this community node that was developed
recently I'll have a link to this GitHub
repo in the description which has
instructions for installing everything
and also an example of how to integrate
with the brave mCP server which is what
I used actually is one of mine so back
in n8n you can go to the settings in the
bottom left this will work if you are
self-hosting n8n or running it locally
and then just go to the community nodes
tab then you can click on install and
then just type in nn- no- mCP and
install it is that easy I do have my own
custom version that I might make a PR
into this main repo at some point it's
not a very mature node there's some
glitches that I was working on fixing
behind the scenes might make a video on
that later as well but yeah back to the
agent here now Within one of these mCP
nodes which you can have as a base node
or as a tool for your agents you can go
in and then you create credentials for
each of the mCP servers that you want to
set up and so very similar to CLA
desktop and other apps you have your
main command like npx you've got your
arguments and then your environment
variables you set up all that click save
and then you have all these tools
available like you can list the tools
for the mCP server list prompts you can
execute a tool and so I've got one here
to list the tools for brave and then
another to execute any given Brave tool
within the mCP server and so feel free
to download this template available in
the description if you want to see how I
prompted the agent to work with these
different mCP servers just got a couple
uh examples here so brave and then
convex but it's yeah it's pretty neat so
I can open this chat and now I can say
search the web for Elon musk's net worth
the kind of thing that an llm would
definitely not be able to do by itself
and so you'll see that first it's
calling the tool to see what Brave tools
are available because it knows that
that's for web search and then it
executes one to search the web and there
we go we got his net worth yep $323
billion which is down more than a 100
billion from December by the way very
interesting the very last implementation
I want to show you is how you can create
custom mCP clients in Python to use them
in AI agents built with Frameworks like
pantic AI which we're using right here
and so you can dive into the python SDK
documentation more and feel free to
download this template as well but yeah
I just import a couple of things from
mCP and then I use those down here to
define the server that I want to connect
to and then I create a client session
that I then use within my agent because
what I do with the client is I gather a
list of tools with this helper function
that I have here so it calls into mCP
grabs the tools for the server packages
them all together as penic AI tool
definitions so it includes the
description and the arguments for the
tools and everything and then I just
feed that in as the tools TOS to my
pedantic AI agent just like I would do
if I defined all of the tools in code
just in like tools. piy or something
else here it is that easy to set up a
client and then use that within pantic
AI you could do something very similar
with any other framework like crew AI or
the open AI SDK as well if you wanted
and so now in my terminal I can just run
the python script just like usual and
then chat with this agent you can see
that it loads the file system server
tells me what my directory is and I can
say something like hide and it won't use
the tool just normal conversation but
then I can say what files are available
and it'll call upon that tool using the
mCP server directly to tell me the files
that I have in this folder and yep that
is the right answer so yeah I definitely
want to do a dedicated video on building
these clients into custom AI agents so
let me know in the comments if you be
interested in that specifically cuz I
think I might really lean into this so
that is everything that I wanted to
cover for MC P except for a very
important final note that I want to
leave with you and that's on the future
of the model context protocol cuz here's
the thing who knows in the near future
if another standardization is developed
that's better and makes mCP obsolete I
don't think it's going to happen but
even if it does it's still really
important for us to dive into this
protocol because anthropic is doing a
great job with this so no matter what
kind of standardization ends up being
King in the next half decade or decade
it's going to look very similar to this
and just getting acquainted with these
standardizations for adding tools into
llms is very important for us because
this is just a higher level
understanding that we want to unlock as
developers and people just building
things with AI and anthropic also has an
incredible road map outlined here I
think they really have a good Vision
behind mCP and really making this the
king of standardization for agents like
remote mCP support I mean if you notice
we were running all of our servers
locally right now but being able to have
them up and running in the cloud having
our clients just connect to them in the
cloud even things like authentication
authorization and starting to monetize
mCP servers I'm sure that's going to be
a thing as well it's super important and
like agent support like this gets me
fired up adding in the ability for
complex agentic workflows with mcps and
having sub agents that are directly
supported as mCP servers hierarchical
agent system like oh man so many
incredible things that we can build into
this standard ation just to make all
these powerful concepts with AI that are
already doable with agentic workflows
and advanced tools and stuff but it this
just makes it so much more accessible to
less technical people for us to share
tools and ideas with each other this
just gets me so fired up and that's why
I want to dive in so much to everything
related to mCP so I hope this video gave
you everything that you need to
understand mCP at a high level and how
you can use it right now and please let
me know in the comments what you want me
to dive into in more detail for my next
mCP related video there are just so many
more things that I could go into a lot
more depth on like creating your own mCP
server integrating with n8n creating
these clients into your pantic AI agents
a lot more I could do so if you
appreciated this content you're looking
forward to more things AI agents and mCP
I would really appreciate a like and a
subscribe and with that I will see you
in the next video